Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Would You Rather?
Now we've got an interesting question right off the bat
Would you rather be a famous athlete in the Olympics known all around the world, or,
Be a famous actor known only in America?
Now I don't know how you could be an actor in projects that are made in America because they are strewn about the world
But let's assume that we're taking this very literally if you're an actor in America
And you're famous you're only known to the people in America
And if you're an American in America acting to Americans that might be all you care about, but let's assume
that I care about more because being a famous athlete means that I'm
Ripped as shit
very capable
but
Probably not gonna be ever as famous as that actor because to be known around the world like I'm assuming we're thinking
Usain Bolt level of famous Olympic athlete who is probably the most famous Olympic athlete right now
He is very well-known, but at the same time
I don't know if he has the same future
potential because if you're a famous actor you can snuff out and day like that's obvious but if you're a famous athlete
Your fame is only localized to the peak years of your life
And then maybe after that you get left alone and you can coach
And you can teach like if you're a famous actor only known in America
I- *Computer sounds*- OUgh
Excuse you- I don't know if you're gonna go very far. I think I'd rather be the famous athlete
Hey and people agree with me, okay, good, good to know.
Would you rather be- be the president or be a Pokemon trainer?
I don't know why anyone would actually want to be the president
Why would you want that kind of stress in your life when you could be a Pokemon trainer?
Which is equally probably boring because?
you'd probably end up being one of those Pokemon trainers that just
Is one of the people that Ash encounters on the road or one of the fodder people?
Well, I guess then you'd live in a world with Pokemon, but see me I've never really cared about Pokemon
Okay, this is where I'm probably gonna divide the entire audience in half.
I've never really been that big of a fan of Pokemon
I watched it as a kid. I played Red, and then I was done because that's really all you needed to know and the-
Where the places where it's gone, I mean I've even played like Pokemon Go a little bit, and then I stopped
But. I just, I don't know I don't really want
Pokemon to be real because I don't want to I don't want to deal with that on a day-to-day basis
You know I don't want. I don't want to walk out the door and have animals start shooting lightning at me
You know I don't- I don't want I don't wanna cat, you know, that's not really a cat. You know
I like Chica the way Chica is I'm assuming wait no if I'm a Pokemon trainer and then pokemon exists in real life
I'm gonna assume that that means that all the animals that currently exist don't exist anymore and if i have to live in a world without Chica
I ain't gonna live in that world
So I'd rather be the President sheerly out of the fact that Chica is more important to me than any goddamn Pokemon
And I will fight you on that one
This is mah fightin face
Would you rather taste the same flavor of food or taste nothing ever again
So you're saying would I rather taste only one flavor of food- can that flavor be chicken and dumplings can it be something
That's like very complex like chicken and dumplings could that be the only flavor that I have because if that's what I got
Then I'm fine with that or could that be cheese the flavor of cheese the flavor of like
Gouda or cheddar or something like that wait no hey, whoa whoa everybody hold up if you can taste nothing ever again
Which would suck it would suck, but that means food
only becomes a thing of sustenance to you, so you never have to binge eat
You never really get joy out of eating, but you can get joy out of other things, too
And you remove control of this one thing in your life like you wouldn't have to worry about dieting ever again
You would only eat as much as you need
The same thing would happen if you taste the same flavor so you might as well make that flavor something good
And then it's bland and then it's monotonous, but that's the only thing like food is food. It's like a dog eating rocks
They're still happy,
those rocks probably taste the exactly the same across the board and you know they would love to get treats
But if a dog doesn't have treats, you know that dogs still gonna be happy because other things in life give it joy.
So I'm gonna go with that. I'm gonna go with the same flavor. Yeah.
Would you rather have stretchable legs or stretchable arms?
hmmm, I don't
You know I never been faced with this conundrum, so just like I could either be really tall at all times
*Laughs*
Or be  real gorilla-like at all times
So I mean it's kind of like
I guess having stretchable arms would be really useful because then you could play a piano across the room
Stretchable arms you could like do surgery on a patient like way down there while relaxing on a bridge
but if you had stretchable legs you could kick someone in the shins like from really far away
or
When- when you say you're gonna shove your boot up their ass you could actually like really do it
like that's an advantage
If you have stretchable arms you can like- you know when they do that thing at weddings and such where they wrap arms around each
Other well you can do like a fancy multi spiral
And then really sip it down and and untangle like have a little bit of flourish at the end there.
These are not really useful-
useful things. If you had stretchable legs you could wear really long pants and
Then you could not wear really long pants
You have the preference that flexibilities thing is something you can't buy with money if you have really long arms
Then you could hug like 20 people at once
you could be like- I could go to a panel be like "bring it in" and
Blulu- Oh hey Chica! How's it going? sorry I booped your nose-
If you had stretchable legs you could- you could if you miss your flight, and it's already taken off
You could be like wait open the door and just leg up and step
In and then leg back, okay?
If you had really long arms you could- you could uh- you could do that thing to your friend?
We stretch around tap them on the other shoulder, but you're like across the room
And they'll have no idea what's going on cuz they're totally alone
They think they're- they think no one's there if you have really long legs you could- you could- you could really own
Hopscotch you would do great at it. Maybe? If you had really long arms
You could reenact that scene from Space Jam where Michael Jordan went up and was like
My arms real stretchy, and then slam dunk it. You just have to get some Monstars with you
If you had stretchable legs that means you could stretch them in right so if someone like tries to punch at you
Instead of going like up you go down. You're like
Whoop!
And you just kind of *Whoop* down, and then you go up again
And you do the thing where you make your legs all stretchy
And you're like whoa and you like
make your legs you do that thing that was a that's a fun maneuver if you had stretchable arms you could like go into a
Vending machine and like snake around stretchable arms it just seems to be winning, okay
Yeah, that that makes a lot of sense
Okay
Would you rather find out your girlfriend is pregnant as in the next ten seconds or find out you can never have kids again?
Uh.
Well, I don't really want kids right now, this is a doozy as a question
I think I'm gonna go with the not having kids because I don't even know if I want kids, I don't
Maybe but you can adopt. Adopting is fine. I just don't want to find out if someone's pregnant
I've gotta go with I'm gonna go with never having kids cuz
Adoption always an option!
lose your front teeth in a skateboarding accident or break your hands on a bike?
Are you- di- wha-
Did I just did I punch a bike? Did I break my hands trying to get into the gears is this some horrible stretchy-arm
Accident where I tried to like pedal with my stretchy arms and they got caught in the gears and is all like snap
Crackle and pop and I'm all like "Ah!
Damn these stretch hands. I should have gone with stretch legs"
I could have been biking a really tall  bikes
you know those bikes that are like the big wheel in the small wheel that were old you could bike one of those?
with stretchy legs
Shit, I'll break my hands. I'll break my hands is what I say all right?
Would you rather be a sports star or a celebrated academic?
Let's go academic? I don't want to get I don't wanna get hurt
I'll go academic. No one's gonna hurt being I can be the really long-legged stretchy legged academic. That's so that's my secret
Oh, yeah, I'll go academic. I'll go academic
Also like the future potential of an academic is a little higher than a sports star.
Alright, would you rather lose- Ohhhhhhhh
Lose your mind or lose your significant other
Oh do they die I'm guessing that means they die Oh?
Or do they just break up with me because that would be better. I guess losing your mind
That's such a horrible thing, but also losing your significant other they
Euh. Oh Aw. I don't wanna. Ohhh
God goddamn losing your mind
To some kind of like degenerative disease. This is a hard one. Maybe it doesn't mean death
Maybe they just break up with me which would be better than death it wouldn't be good, but at least no one's
Permanently disabled, or dead.
Let's see I wouldn't want to live if I knew that my mind was gone permanently
but then I wouldn't know so like in my
Rational moment right now. I wouldn't want to do that but losing your significant other
That's a horrible thing and I wouldn't wish that on anyone
I see if it came down to a choice of me dying or my significant other dying
I would of course choose myself like a that's no question, but this isn't really that choice. Is it? I don't know like
I gotta go with lose your mind if I had to make a choice
You know I I if I have to put this as a choice of like me
Versus my significant other that I gotta go with me. I just gotta go yeah, I'll bear that oh
God that's such a rough one. Would you rather soil yourself and have nobody no or not so yourself
but everyone thinks you did well I
Mean, this is quite a quite a 180 from the last one
I'll shit my pants and have nobody know because I'll just deal with that I'd rather not
Everyone think I shat my pants because that shit will come back to haunt you in ghosts form- ghost poop
I'll go with soil myself. All right, would you rather listen to Rebecca Black or Justin Bieber?
I'm gonna go with some good old Jay Biebs. Oh go Jay awe
Would you rather eat every meal mix with carbonara sauce or drink every drink mixed with four loko? Oh?
I'm loco for four loko give me some four l.... I mean. I'll die I can't drink alcohol so that doesn't work
I mean carbonara sauce that's not bad if I just eat pasta all the time
That's not the worst thing in the world. I guess yeah, I get that
I just can't drink I would go for the four loko, but I die I can't drink alcohol
would you rather have your left leg be painlessly amputated and only be allowed to be use a peg leg as a pro-
*GASPS*
Be a pirate?? Because that's what happens if you get a peg leg you are a pirate
That's all you do. I have to grow a beard. I have to live on a ship
I have to go out and have scurvy. I have to rob people on the Seas. I have a sword I have a parrot that's amazing
What's even the other one?
I don't even need to know have one of your toes be amputated with the dirty cleaver every year until you have none left
Yeah, I'm gonna be the fucking pirate. I'm gonna be a pirate
Fuck yeah, would you rather pull all of your toenails out or pull all of your hair out I?
Just imagine like oh god cuz I have Trypophobia, I just imagine like
Although a hair getting ripped out in the aftermath Oh oh no my skin scrawled oh, no
I'm gonna go with the toenail not because like it'd be preferable
But just because I don't have to deal with the other one
Oh god the visual of that is killing my mind
would you rather kill Godzilla and have half the city destroyed because of it everyone will know you or kill the Kraken and save the
city from future catastrophe without anybody knowing
oh
Okay
So let's assume that the kra.. Kraken was gonna destroy the city
But nobody dies nobody knows it or Godzilla half the city gets destroyed, but everyone knows you did it
Well, I mean it's really a conundrum like it's not me. That's causing the problem. This is like the car dilemma
You're in a car right you're driving down
There's three people in the road in front of you you were gonna hit them. No matter what your brakes are gone
You cannot stop, but you can swerve, but if you swerve
There's one person in the road you will kill that one person or you will kill three whether or not by your inaction
What you can do nothing about it?
You will kill three people or you can do something about it, and it will kill one person. That's like the moral dilemma
It's your active choice to kill that one person
But if you don't act three people will die.
For me the answer is obvious. or- or like actually no there was social status behind it,
it's like three old people or three thieves and criminals versus one
mother. It's like do you
Sacrifice one for the good of the many few for the many or that
but this is not to do with any of this this is just for self gratification so of course I would be an asshole if
I pick half the city, but everyone knows me. I'm a hero but only in my mind
But they don't know that but no one knows that anything will happen. Maybe these just happen
And I I do that but to be perfectly honest, okay, let's just be rational about this the Kraken lives in the ocean
I ain't going in the fucking ocean. It ain't gonna happen
I ain't gonna do that.
I'm sorry. I can't do that. I gotta go with Godzilla
Sorry, I'm sorry. I'm sorry half the city. I can't go in the ocean. Okay
Oh, oh oh God
Wow okay, would you rather be stalked by a ghost for your entire life?
Or be stalked by a demon for three days
And then die
I'm gonna assume that this isn't a ghost that you can communicate with this is a ghost that's always there
Always haunting you
Always trying to mess with you or a demon
Who's gonna kill you in three days?
It's whether you- you- it's the question of whether you can live with a ghost scaring you every day of your life
Or you die in three days to a demon either way, it's gonna happen
And I'm gonna leave this one up to you not because I don't want to see it
Kinda, I mean, I don't want to deal with it
But I want to leave you guys with something so which would you rather do and why?
Why would you be okay-
The ghost is not gonna be your friend
the ghost is not gonna like you the ghost hates you it's like the ghost of your worst enemy and
this ghost just wants to mess with you and ruin your life all your life or
You're gonna die from a demon
That's what it is, so I'll leave it up to you give your justification down the comments below
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh-bye!!!